ding-ding-ding-ding-ding not militant
who wedding if I will yeah how come is a
Jenna and Jillian relaxed cat okay let's
introduce that before we just have it
don't we belong it I locked my phone to
shut it off and it should stop playing
usually doesn't do that it usually has
like background plan I change the
setting we were looking what you did no
why would you do that would be
impossible
how are you honor why oh do I owe told
please welcome back guys to the podcast
we're this week we are going to talk
about what we like to do to relax that's
it yeah well we need a relaxed cast
because my ox chest he had some stress
anxiety dreams and we'll get back that
house that kind of it well it's great
cause worried about it but now that's
going I mean I have I have food and
naturebox to help me and gets released
ow oh my god are you guys gonna have any
luck too
so check it out they got hundreds of
awesome for over us are over 100 snacks
at a straight and are actually better
for you then most of the snacks that
you're probably eating right now simple
ingredients quality ingredients no
artificial colors flavors or sweeteners
right now you get three free snacks with
your first order you go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julian that's
naturebox.com/tyler and Julian also stop
losing you can you stop losing your
wallet stop losing your important things
with tracker tracker pixel is trackers
new tiny little tiny little tracker
device that you put on your things that
you lose you put it on anything like
your keys or your backpacks or your dog
or your throne or your cat your outdoor
cat like my dad and it will alert you
when you track it down with your pocket
and connects to the tracker app and it
can play a 90 decibel alert sound that
will help you find your lost item in
seconds
it is it is an amazing device I've used
it a lot and they have a 30 day money
back guarantee so right now you can try
to go into the tracker that's th e TR
ACK our comm promo code engine get 20%
off any order Thank You sponsors thank
you something well yeah so we decided to
have mover channels in here I think in
guys we got candle every time soon I'm
wearing MOPP pajama shorts and my
glasses usual rule number one of
relaxing is that you can't have your
contact lenses in for me that's true and
for me it's like put classified because
I'm likely watching the screen really
yeah
like our glasses at night when I'm when
I'm watching TV or playing games yeah
come on computer we need to we need to
relax during freezing for last-minute
trips tomorrow morning very exciting
I'm very excited by the time you guys
are watching us we'll be on our way back
already
yeah that's good you think I know it's
also crazy to think about that we're
going again because it never feels like
a full month is past it like it's so
funny because this room is their only
game in the we podcast and those of you
that watched a live stream they throw
the dart in this room like your methods
right here and like how cool is it going
to be to watch like that map continue to
fill up with little pins really cool
it's there somewhere that you're helping
to go because don't let Julian for you I
feel like you guys like have hopes that
you use places that you're hoping to go
so yeah I mean I think subconsciously we
both have built up you know images of
what certain places might have or these
sweet fantasies or whatever so be fair
though you're a human being and you're
throwing a dart at a map and you're
going to go where it lands but like I
would prefer the dart to land in certain
places over other place yeah the
difference TV in common is we both hope
for some things he just can't tame a
dart Oh rifle they're not he likes us he
answered Hawaii every time hit like
Kansas last wait so where would oh where
would you have to hit it in order to hit
Hawaii down in the bottom there yeah
right it's a little it's a little inset
in a box yeah I'm about yeah yeah so
when you guys so you guys can't win a
four-point Washington when you when you
went to point Washington Florida just
below that is a box that shows a picture
of Hawaii is that where you'd have to
throw the dart in order to go to Hawaii
yeah he's gonna drive in anything Hawaii
again he and we're gonna be stuck on a
Florida again keep the reason we were
there I think I think maybe that was my
dog is everything a blindfolded yeah
we're doing a bamboo the Dinkin actually
got us blindfolds like wob school
last-minute blindfolds is this the first
trip you guys are going to be using your
custom bag yes it is they're sitting
right up top there someone got actually
not someone shares a rally I think and a
whole group of Dinks pulled together
pull together and goddess T is awesome
just let me get him right now
go get them Julian that's so rad I like
I literally was like crying and she is
this is it last minute is done but cable
to attorney and me and it has our
initials engraved and it says last
minute trip so I got a dart case and
everything the whole dark it's so I
called any thrown them yet no well now
I'm not going to I'm not gonna throw us
all this time
no I mean just to make sure that they
dart always taking apart the board I
tested up yeah from you but I'm not
anyway that you're helping me though
what a Rochester knew I'd like to go to
the North East Rochester me I like this
one from the Northeast only it's a
beautiful time of year I mean I've never
ever really spent aside to like New York
and Boston rule the slime I'm on I mean
I'm on remarkably you know it's in the
ranks cast to regional oh he gave me bad
guys right now you get the chili sauce
for it and anything calm it's a super
relaxed it sure is only a good know what
not know okay so how did you go from
being so triggered by a fly to like
telling people to get a waffle cool
shirt because the fly reminded me that
these shirts are flying off the shelves
oh my elated God Church there's some law
I just want to let people know where God
Church yeah so I'd like to see some
trees I'd like to
I don't know just going northeast but
I've been again okay I want them to
Rochester with you I don't go by myself
that would be hysterical if I went there
without you yeah or if you made it on
some part in upstate New York like you
had to go to like Binghamton or
something like sigh I really like to go
there with you if you went with me I'll
take you to Rochester but then I would
drive down to like walkins go in and
stuff yeah
anywhere anywhere in that whole East
Coast region like I'd love to I've never
been anywhere around there what you were
saying he wanted to go to Vermont
Vermont like North Carroll well I didn't
know sell out with you yeah
Tennessee I went to Kentucky Bourbon too
I've been to every state up there
everything we're never been to Alabama
Georgia South Carolina I don't think
I've ever been to there's just a lot of
it I haven't seen out there I mean I
would I'll be down for anywhere I'm
arrested in New Hampshire yeah I know
you hate it in Rochester hell yeah
marble shut up go fertilize sound of a
tiny dog barking I do want to touch on
the thing that you brought up which is
the stress and the stuff that I've been
dealing with which is like I first want
to say that like a lot of you guys when
I blogged about it which was just you
know sometimes I get more open in the
vlog than others right like sometimes we
just feel like you need to talk a little
bit you have nothing to give but like
your honest life and this week I talked
about the stress and anxiety I've been
having while I sleep and so I have this
recurring thing where I wake up and I
think I'm still streaming live on Twitch
and I get really nervous and I get
anxiety and I'm convinced it's happening
it's not like a dream it just feels
really real and it's recurring it's
every single night and I don't think
it's because I'm sharing on Twitch I
don't think it's because of one thing or
another thing I think it's just because
my routine isn't really giving me enough
time to like wind down wind down and
just chill but I do want to say thank
you to all of you guys who have been so
kind and supportive and you know
outreaching to me on the Internet
ever since I posted that I'm fine I'm
good we'll deal with it you know it's
just one of those things it's a learning
variants and I don't feel like I'm
burning out because I know what that
feels like I've done that before I don't
feel like I'm burning out are you still
sure a little bit of stress yeah but you
do have a lot on your plate you know
yeah like I know I say this all the time
but like I'm a [ __ ] Virgo okay I can't
just throw dart at a map and [ __ ] go
there
okay then I'll freak out the whole time
because I need to make a plan first you
know so just the fact that you know
you've been feeling that level of stress
with a lot of things going on and then
you're leaving in the morning to
who-knows-where like that's a lot right
now yeah yeah yeah it takes a lot of
prep like you guys don't see all the
prep that you guys do beforehand to get
ready for that trip so it's a lot yeah
and honestly I love it I'm growing
episode 5 and I've had such a great time
this is in the ride of a lifetime and
we're only getting started which is so
exciting like I regret nothing I'm so
happy that we started this I'm so happy
that you guys support it but yet I want
to go the map can be a little bit
stressful sometimes I guess stress yeah
sometimes I'm just like [ __ ] that I'm
sleeping through your dart thrill let me
know where you guys are going I mean you
don't have to deal with any of this Jeff
yeah exactly
or others like the second-hand stress or
I'll wake up and then you'll text me
like alright I'm gonna send it I said oh
post me is the camera with the gun yeah
oh my god
but I wanted to talk about some things
that were relaxing and we can remember
quite again it won't even bring Bob on
the scene here get that little bobble
booth who Julian's wearing his meat
undies ah jogging pants or like really
soft ones and I just thought a lot when
he walked on home well I hope that
Julian and Collin throw the dart at Los
Angeles California and have to say I
don't want to believe what is this going
to think about you did a handstand
Marvel did yeah mom ball are you having
a rough time body being marry your
daughter or you go and you try to pick
them up they lean a certain way to try
to I get away or go into you and then so
while let's do that look at you two
always do that a lot though because
they're like kind of top-heavy yeah like
you ever seen koala there
videos of them like when they're peeing
is cold outside mildew a handstand or
like when they're eating we'll do it
here and puppies do it has enough Marvel
I mean is he's working in ads I know he
was on the floor looking Nadia toe my
boy barking it and she's today it's
modern food what relaxes you okay so I
want to talk about this I've been
hearing the sound a lot like the hell
yeah
the same because
Hill so um I used to listen to a lot of
like guided meditations like when I was
a kid I had this kiss that tape that my
grandma gave me actually that was called
like guardian angels or something and it
was just really like nice sounding like
rain and quiet stuff and then a woman
talking you through like you meet your
guardian angel and you like slide down a
rainbow together and like hold hands and
it's like really cute and she just gave
it to me my grandma was a little
eclectic she was you know a lot but uh
she gave it to me and I think my mom was
like oh those mother weird thing that
grandma gave you whatever but I wanted
like loving it and I listen to it every
single night so I've been listening to
like that kind of thing more like
guidance Allah guided meditations at
night for a long time like since I was a
kid but I recently got into and if you
go on YouTube YouTube is the best
[ __ ] place in the world and I'm
obsessed with it every single day
everything is like yeah I just like I
fall in love with YouTube like over and
over and over and over and over and even
when we talked about this on podcast
where you know we're mad at YouTube and
people are like well if you guys are so
accept with the platform and what's
going on why don't you just leave it and
do something else like the answer status
because we're so mad because everybody
loves YouTube so much no II don't want
to be ruined yeah and we're like we're
fighting and you know we're calling them
all or holding them accountable because
if we don't do it no one's going to do
that you know the platform's going to
turn into whatever it's going to turn
into whatever's going to make them the
most money or whatever so yeah what
we're fighting for what makes it great
but like any time that everything I've
ever learned in my adult life how to do
has been from YouTube and like it's just
amazing so you know I was looking for
some guided meditation because I was
using an app a while back but I wasn't
like the greatest and I started getting
into like just the tones or like just
the frequencies and Julian actually got
me some sleep phones because Julian
listen about sleep burned asleep
Julian listens to this podcast called
seamlessly with many projects I'll talk
about that in a sec but sleeping
basically a headband with built in like
speaker headphone yeah so you don't so
you can sleep on them without them
hurting her and it's really funny
because that's one of their podcast
sponsors and Julian was like I want to
get some sleep phones and I'm like ah
that's funny and it's cute who he gets
them and it's like the most adorable
little headband and he sleeps with it
every night I got super jealous it was
like chewing I want some [ __ ] sleep
phone so he got me some and I've been
listening to like just the hurts like
frequencies and there's all different
kinds and then when you fall down that
rabbit hole there's ones of like
decalcifying your pineal gland or like
opening your third eye which I've been
trying to do for years I mean that
serious okay so I remember I like
tweeted out one time like oh I'm sorry I
can't come to your birthday party I'm
opening my son guys just like a half
joke like I am genuinely interested in
that stuff and I got a bunch of like
very serious tweets back like oh it's
really not that hard you some gentle
meditation just want to help you open I
know they really just want to help me so
what happened the other night though
tell us what happened the other night
what I mean well you uh you thought
really emotional and you kissed me
remember and you listened
oh yeah so I wasn't going to say that
but that's really I'm sorry do we not
need to talk no no no it's really sweet
so I was listening there's all different
kinds of frequencies at playing arena
yeah killing burner movie this one is
936 Hertz but like if you I just typed
in the letters Hz the frequency or
sounds it's not a very sound oh yeah and
then there's just tons of stuff like a
healing your chakras and you know you
don't have to believe in any of this you
are buying into any of it but this is
just like really nice relaxing spa music
sort of but like if you just sit and
listen to it or fall asleep to it
because I'm a type of person Julian was
like you should listen to the sleep of a
podcast it's really great healthy fall
asleep so I tried it and I really
enjoyed it but I can't listen to someone
speaking any kind of words and fall
asleep because I listen to the word
because it's like multitasking yeah yeah
it's like when I was one of those people
that could never study and listen to
music
I couldn't less it was classical music
yeah
because I was actually become a genius
no answer to know that I'm saying I
couldn't listen to something with like
lyrics because then it has been my train
yeah yeah because actually like I learn
really well audio wise yeah like from
hearing I'm not like a super visual
learners yeah I'm like an audio learner
or like a rewriting at 10 billion times
yeah
same thing here and I could I not only
could I not multitask but I like really
had to focus at on tasks like reading I
really had to really focus because if I
was even the slightest bit out of it
when I was reading I have to read a page
over like five different times so I know
what you mean like yeah like I like to
sleep with new podcasts I feel like I
can listen to that like an hour before
bed and like one down you know what I
mean yeah but I just can't like take my
mind off of someone's words but for
someone like you like that really like
makes you really sleepy yeah and you
know what I think so I don't remember
where you know what's crazy
and I have no clue where I heard of the
sleep with me pocket I think you're just
looking up a bunch of odd cash but like
I had this weird distinctive remember
like memory of someone telling me to
listen to that podcast and I have no
clue what that was which is so weird to
me because maybe I was searching I don't
know I don't know how I found it but I
looked one up on YouTube or night and I
I think I was just like stressed out
about stuff and I just like I wasn't
ready to go to sleep and I wanted to go
to sleep so I like put it on and I like
laid down and for the first night guy
talking yeah so his name's scooter and
he has this very interesting voice and
he talks in a way that is like a like a
lot of like vocal fry' yeah it's exactly
but it's also like his cadence is not
stop and he he stumbles upon his words
but almost in like an intentional way
right he handled myself the intention
like he intentionally mumbles ease away
don't embarrass house is sort of like oh
whatever it's like nonsense but then it
really just goes into complete nonsense
yeah it goes into complete nonsense and
what's crazy is like it actually put me
to sleep and I'm just not ready for that
I was just like okay I want to listen to
this podcasting my him up and then it
put me to sleep and then it kind of
served as like this thing for me where
no matter what was going on sales on the
road or because I have trouble sleeping
a hotel room sometimes or I was you know
without yeah it's almost sleeping yeah
no it's true and I'm not with you I
don't sleep well and I'll yeah I think
well I just had trouble going to sleep
and I'm like not with I'm not you know
with my other half and that was the big
big thing for me like when I when I was
not with you and I needed to just like
remove myself from that like anxiety or
whatever it's like that's what that was
perfect for me and now I listen to it
all the time you know it's not like I
don't know it doesn't it definitely
relaxes me and like I did fall asleep to
it one night I gave it like a good shot
but it's the the fact that it just has
words I already know that my like brain
doesn't shut off when I'm listening to
someone talk you know like but the
sounds really make the hurts can do you
like know like what's behind how
different hurts that sounds like do
different things mental what I mean
according to so I'm not educated yeah
just something like that ever yeah but
it seems like some of them do different
things and I definitely prefer some of
them over other ones but what Julian was
saying was like tell me what you said
the other night
so like some of them definitely I don't
know what I'm picking out one like some
of them will make you like feel
something for me they like make me feel
something like and like my god or like
just say like resonate with me
totally so now I'll take that one and
I'll listen to and I'll fall asleep but
so I was I was listening to one the son
was like some talking ocean is Dean I
was listening to one and I started to
get like really emotional like I was
just like thinking like you know I'm
like drifting off into sleep and you
know your mind's like sort of just
wandering like you're not thinking you
know I mean and I started to just feel
myself get really emotional and I like
felt like I was going to cry and so I
was like reading the comments in one of
these videos which by the way are
completely hysterical usually like
something some of them are really really
like wonderful and sweet and thoughtful
and amazing
but then there's other works where it's
like do not listen like extreme
out-of-body experience which I promise
you I've listened to that like I did not
have nada body experience okay I just
went to [ __ ] to sleep and it was amazing
but some of them so trollee and
hysterical and the contents I wish I
could find some it's going to take me
too long to find any but I was reading
the comments and I found somebody else
that said and they're like I don't know
why after like you know half an hour of
this like I started to feel really
emotional and crying it's almost like oh
don't worry that's just your heart
chakra opening up keep going and I was
like and I was my heart chakra yeah oh
interesting I need to tap into certain
things that you feel like are just you
know inaccessible I feel like I've been
falling down this like hurts
relaxing role or whatever and
coincidentally I'm kidding
my favorite show ancient aliens just did
an episode called alien frequency where
they realized that a bunch of those like
giant megalithic structures or whatever
all across the world like I'd forget
Teotihuacan and like Machu Picchu or
like other places yeah they found all
resonated when they took a thing that
measured Hertz
I'm sorry this is very not scientific
they all measured the same sound
frequencies which which leads you have
won the episode because I'm not doing
that
explanation Jessel was there like it was
like it was like eleven hundred Hertz or
something like that that they were all
like all these places across the world
were all resonating with that frequency
and they even said that some of the
structures the way that they were built
were clearly used for sound so like if
you played a sound in one part of the
room it would balance perfectly back and
forth to make the entire space resonate
at that frequency which I thought was
really fascinating because like I only
takes me a little bit of listening to
something like this they start actually
feeling something inside of my body you
know I mean like it makes me feel
different it makes me feel good every
different Hertz is a certain one
um different one okay not all of them
yeah some of them definitely make you
feel different like the ones that are
higher like in number like the nine
hundred something something hurts the
ones that are meant to activate your
third eye which by the way I have some
of these sorry some of these like
bizarre clicking noises in them which
are very scary in the first time you're
not expecting them it's like what is it
it's decalcifying your third eye just
old but some of the higher ones I feel
like you feel them I feel them like in
my head more even in like my Chester
body the lower ones I feel like I feel
in my chest and body but it's not
interesting like the idea of Oh inches
uh a good sound so interesting I forget
where I saw it it was uh where was it
but they were showing that in Tibet or
whatever they have these wheels with
just where it was a janae lead to think
they have these just big I hate my life
they have these wooden wheels you have
just words on them and as the monks walk
by they spin the wheel because they feel
like just having the word touch the air
like the air is alive and just spinning
it the act of doing that puts the word
into the air and into the universe like
that's enough to get that do you know
I'm saying no no I mean the world but
the whole this whole thing was very
interesting with me I mean I would love
to mess around and listen and see what
like what happens with I just yeah I
just love the idea that without a sacred
yeah it makes so like perfect sense to
me like music does so much for so many
people and people find it therapeutic
there's like Reiki healing and that kind
of thing and music and sound that people
find very healing and relaxing and
calming there's a lot of power in
something stuff I feel like I'm sort of
just like scratching the surface but
it's been really really really nice so I
put on my sleep bones and I listen to
this and I'm like oh alright well I'm
just so sorry is literally never
happened well it's been a really long
time
have some technical difficulty like like
that arc memory card corrupted while we
were recording I need in that first 30
minutes is a little pixelated he said
yeah there's a glitch there's glitches
that are going on so you probably have
clean which is throughout okay Emma's so
we just reported like an hour and we
just had a really interesting
conversation many companies and then
realized that the red light wasn't on it
was blinking to the memory card broke
nice looks like so we're going to pick
up the discussion here it's obviously
not gonna be the same we're going to try
it is just like oh I also don't know
exactly where we left off yeah man I'm
really sorry guys I think you're talking
about the heart's frequencies yeah I
think we were to this broken episode of
damage in progress
that's negative now it's mid-roll we're
going to do sponsors is brought to you
by tracker pixel sorry guys definitely
sucked uh yeah don't know what to do
like yeah life is supposed to be a
journey of discovery China will and
stuff the relaxing stuff not trying to
find your keys
eight years ago tracker changed
everything when they release their first
tracking device and now they've done it
again with all the new the all new
tracker pixel you never have to worry
about losing your things again tracker
pixel is the lightest Bluetooth tracking
device device on the market just put
your tackle tracker pixel on what every
time to lose your keys your wallet your
dog's your cat your phone your drone
your backpack and when you lose an item
that has a tracker pixel attached to use
your smartphone in a 90 decibel where it
will help you find it in seconds even
has a power powerful LED lights you can
help find anything even them dark last
time I lost my phone you guys thought I
pull over there and I beeped it with the
tractor pixel and you can also find your
pet your phone with your tracker pixel
which is very cool you can even find
your item if it's miles away because
every tracker user is part of the
largest crowd network in the world and
trackers 30 day money-back guarantee
means you'll truly have nothing to lose
get it right now go to the tracker
that's th e TR ACK our comm promo code
genna's you'll need to get 20% off any
order that's th e TR ACK our comm also
guys and there was a sick transition let
me tell you on this because it was fire
naturebox
is also sponsoring us this week as we
all want to eat better when it comes to
some
nice pretty damn hard trust me I know I
smack pretty badly when I live naturebox
naturebox calm has over a hundred snacks
that taste good and are actually better
if you made from quality ingredients and
you'll fear but feel better about what
you're snagging on i'm celiac and we're
vegan and there are plenty of snacks
that we like we have the Mesa crisps and
the strawberry lemon-aid food stars
which are amazing it's so easy you
should a naturebox.com/tyler and they'll
deliver them right to your door with no
risk if you ever try a snack you don't
like don't eat it naturebox will replace
it for free right now naturebox giving
three free snacks in your first order
for the naturebox.com/tyler Julian
that's naturebox.com/tyler enjoying so
how do we do this man I'm just I feel
really bad I'm sorry guys I feel that
too but it's also like I don't know what
I don't know what to do I just think I
think it's so funny that this happened
we're doing some stress and having a lot
of stress and we're like let's just do a
nice relaxing podcast where we talk
about relaxing and the most stressful
thing happens and like I know a lot of
you guys are probably like why don't you
just like start it over and whatever
look we don't really have time to start
it over you know we really don't have
time Oh what are we talking about
context that they're talking about the
Hertz frequency sounds and I don't know
how far we got into that but that sound
is sacred and it can heal you and I
talked about the the monks with the
words on those wooden wheels and they
were I and just active moving you the
word superimposes it into the air
because I think that air is alive and
the buildings I watched an episode of
ancient aliens where they showed that a
bunch of different megalithic structures
and places all vibrate at the same
frequency which is really interesting
but then we started talking about which
I don't think if we left off on sound
we were talking about how stress and the
culture of distraction that Millennials
are in and they're in order to like you
know maybe years ago in the past when
people wanted to shut off it wasn't
exactly a choice because I remember even
as a kid like my biggest fear like for
the
summer or something you know when you
have free time was being born yeah like
that was a genuine fear for me yeah I
didn't want to be like alone sitting
doing nothing it was like the worst
thing in the world we know it's the best
thing in the world that's all I look
forward to or nothing but that we're
constantly in this culture of
distraction and that I've actually sat
with myself like a lot I sit with this
idea a lot of like you know I'm I post
on the internet for a living you post on
the internet for a living the podcast
and our main channels you don't know
whatever are we part of the problem are
we adding any values anything or are we
just perpetuating the culture of
distraction and that's like a discussion
that there is no answer at the end of it
because we're all doing we're all doing
it we're all we're all on our phones
were all consumed all the time with
media on the internet and especially
when we're creators who are actively
adding to that pool of distraction it's
feel like that's just a crisis or a
discussion or an inner monologue that
you're going to have for as long as
you're doing it yeah and there's never
going to be a clear answer and it's it's
one of those things where some days
you'll feel like you're contributing
positive things and some days you'll
feel like you'll contributing to the
problem mm-hmm and it's it's it's just a
wild thing and like you always say and I
think this is a really good thing that
you say it resonated a long time ago and
you first said it but the Internet has
no rules really because it's being paved
as we speak right like this this whole
movement online with the internet with
YouTube with content and and Twitter and
instant feedback in this net there are
no like you can't go to the history
books and see how it's done because it's
all going on right as we speak it's like
you know what I mean yeah I think that
is that's part of this discussion where
it's like you may feel like you do
something wrong but there's really no
way to fact-check it right you know I
know I feel like the majority of the
time that I've been on the Internet
there was no like rule book there's no
way to do it and you know there are a
lot of people in suits telling you
you what they think you should do but
it's it's all just sort of intuition
base and you know I've been burned
plenty of times doing things on the
internet but like you sorta just have to
trust your gut and what you think I feel
like I've always just come from a place
of like I want to make things because I
want to make them but it does I still
sit with the idea of am i perpetuating
the culture of distraction and then we
we talked about how even for Millennials
like your because we're talking about
sounds and like sitting with your
thoughts and you know actually
decompressing actually distressing yeah
you know by thinking through some of
your your problems or you know coming to
a solution for yourself and instead we
mash them with all of these distractions
but then your distractions become a new
source of stress we talked about
instagrams you have an incident I'm not
like the biggest fan of in demand
because I don't like the sheer complete
level of superficiality that comes along
with it but that people are you know
developing all kinds of eating disorders
and things from just that being exposed
to other people constantly showing their
body perfection where you know it's just
a very in-your-face vain sort of
platform and in addition I think I added
something along the lines of intagram
also really encourages this culture of
comparing yourself to other people no
matter what in a physical subject is
yeah yeah physically like you versus
another person or even just like success
and wealth and anything you can really
put on Instagram
you're by nature you think you're just
like flipping through and relaxing but
what you're doing is you know you're
comparing yourself to all these people
without even realizing and that's
terrible that's like one of the worst
habits you can have and that's like
growing up I had to really teach myself
so I guess at least identify when I was
doing that really [ __ ] it with my
confidence is just mentality it is
really hard I think that it's something
to that never fully goes away because
you know I like to follow a lot of
people on a long different platform I
follow anybody I listen to anybody I
like you know I've been criticized in
the past for doing that people are like
I can't believe you follow this person
or you've read that or you've done this
or like I feel like I would like to
absorb as much information and opinions
from
people as I can and I don't need to
align with them at all I would just like
to listen to what they have to say but
like I follow a lot of different people
who are you know going to things that
maybe I'm not going through like a like
a mother who gives birth and you know
you see all these comments in there of
people being like wow good for you or
there's other people that are like body
shaming and like it's just like a big
mix of things and I don't think that
ever really goes away that sense of
comparing yourself you say that with new
moms a lot where they're like mom
shaming is not and and like I don't
personally identify with that but I can
see how as your life transitions you
know from being a kid to a young adult
to an adult to a mother to a parent to a
grandparent like you're constantly
comparing yourself to other people your
age it's just that you find a different
level of peace I think at different
stages or if you never find a level of
peace with comparing yourself you know
you're tortured through multiple stages
of life sometimes you're in a real I
think it's not you could be you think
that's the way things are because social
media so everywhere right this is life
yeah and a lot of it you know I think
it's good motivation sometimes like I
was definitely at a point in my life
where in order to just feel even
motivated for something I needed to go
you know look at things that made me
feel motivated like I understand that
yeah but then I also think it comes to a
point where you're just beating yourself
down yeah you know yep
yeah I think that happened and that has
happened to me on certain occasions even
add like a youtuber mmm where it's not
like you know going on internally
comparing like my body another person's
body that's more like like going on
YouTube seeing my peers just by nature
the other creators out there who are
doing this and that and like without
even realizing it's just like the
surfaced interaction that you get from
watching or even looking at some nails
and titles like it's doing things in
your brain it's it's like actually it
makes it so the next time you go to
create you like think about that and you
would call that and you're like oh wait
a minute now now what should I do
should I do something different than
that and then all of a sudden you're
being affected by something that you
no intention on to in fact to be
effective threat and that's like that's
the worst and actually that's like
losing your sense of direction while
also like compromising your sense of
self yeah in them in like the most
bare-bones way it also doesn't help that
if you click on something on YouTube
then they remember what you watched and
suggest other things just like it's like
the machine they like danaher's in your
behavior and it it really is it's like
it's easy even if your habits like are
trying you're trying to change the [ __ ]
you're watching YouTube's like wait what
about this good enough and ah matpat
actually a game theory right that's his
name I'm saying that right [ __ ] man
luckily he did an interesting video
about what he called the fourth
generation of YouTube the first being
like whatever you know seizing baby
panda and Chocolate Rain - then like
Ryan Higa and people like that were
they're the first generation of
youtubers to like you know start posting
on a regular basis on a regular schedule
and then the third generation the
explosion of the daily vloggers and the
you know that kind of thing and then the
fourth generation is the first
generation that has grown up watching
YouTube so they already know how to
manipulate the system and turn it into
what they want it to be in either the
first like actually in genuine hey what
culture what's it capitalize it
capitalize on it in a way to where you
know the the logan Paul's the Jake
Paul's they're creating this perfect
funnel of cross-promotion between
everyone the david dobrik slides of coe
she's where you have an ensemble cast
who all make their own videos that all
coincide with each other and final back
to each other and then the more of them
you watch or like a series of videos
where you need to watch them in a row in
order to understand what's going on and
the more of them that you watch the more
of them are recommended to you
creating a never-ending funnel of like
watch time basically but it's crazy to
think about like we are already living
in the age where you like youtubers are
self-aware enough a sense of like mark
audience is aware if there was a time
where you couldn't talk about the fact
that you even [ __ ] made money or like
that was very taboo and and people
didn't want to talk about it people
would ask you
rude questions about it or be really
rude to about it but now you see your
your audience or people watching your
video many of whom are creators
themselves because everything's doctor
ties everyone is essentially creating
new things out there but they're aware
of it and they they call it out and
they're hypersensitive to it you know
what I mean and gone is the day where
you can just like blatantly lie about
having branded content or sponsored
content because the law is actually
coming for people now you know you're
doing where it used to be you know the
literal Wild West where companies would
verbatim ask you to do things that are
against the law
yeah but they are aware of that your
audience is aware of that everyone's
aware of that yeah
but anyways it is still a culture of
distraction the whole thing is a culture
of distraction we're self conversation
is medical where we're competing with
who can be the most distracting in
essence is that the most so that okay
thank you and we can like clock out and
go be distracted and then get upset by
our distraction yeah oh man what a
terrible prison that is know what okay
sometimes just gotta get out of town
throw dot can I have time all right I
know a lot of people are like why don't
you guys take a vacation like shut off I
don't feel like I need to shut off
because I'm really good about like not
using my phone or like you know not
going on Twitter I don't post I mean you
guys know I like I just don't post I
know I would I I think so like I would
love to go on like go on a physical trip
where I don't like I don't need to force
myself to get off my phone I can do that
it's more about just like taking a trip
with a sole reason like literally like
don't even bring my man my gear okay so
for the sole reason of like into a
mailing the [ __ ] out we've done that a
couple times you have anyway there's
been a really long time since we did a
real real good one of those and I think
a lot has changed in terms of like my
workload and everything that's going on
so I would really like that but I feel
like one of the things that you realize
as you get older is how valuable time is
and how little of it there is
oh man it's really crazy it's crazy to
feel like it's it it's crazy to feel
like it's like evening and 890 m and you
still feel like you have a time to do
and then you want to wake up early
morning but you also want on my play pub
jeans where I am no I mean just like
things that you want to do in your life
and when you're young you feel like you
have your whole life to do it and like
in a general sense yeah then you and
then you realize like how it's like time
is incredibly valuable and how you spend
it is incredibly valuable you know it
better be serving you you know I mean
and something that would serve us or you
know a lot of people probably just take
a little weekend vacation but like for
many people myself included you included
it's like well what weekend can I even
do that yeah it sucks because your time
is all wrapped up another thing yes and
it's good it's good because like I said
it life is good and you're being busy is
great and having a passion in it and
doing something that you love for work
is great it is just so important though
to remember the way bigger picture at
the end of the day like when all that
goes away you know you're on this earth
for a finite amount of minutes mm-hmm
Wow Wow
might as well be stressed out the whole
time whole time might as well have your
SD card break made podcast
I've never happened that actual problem
hasn't happened to us but this SD card
has been a workhorse for like almost two
years but still don't do that don't
[ __ ] do that SD card I don't like I
wish an SD card had like you know
batteries the ones where you can press
both ends and it tells you how much
battery is left
you can press both ends of your SD card
and tells you how long it's going to be
until it just [ __ ] shits the bed
imagine if you did that and just snap
the f ck yeah thank you so much so much
but it's like the problem I had
formatted it so there was no footage but
then it filled up which means TED talks
like this Scott's broken but hopefully
you guys got something out of podcast
even though it was kind of spliced into
sections in the first section had like a
whole bunch of glitches I think home
screen I'm not sure put a relaxing
podcast this is one of those podcasts
where I'd be really interesting really
interested to hear your thoughts on like
the Hertz thing we were talking about
I'd love to hear any responses on that
you guys feel passionate about and also
just you know whatever you feel time in
and more you dogs I feel like I'm like
my mom new ever since I was a little kid
in order for me to feel relaxed I feel
physically different when I'm around
animals that's why she would always let
me have hamsters and stuff even though
she was allergic to cats and dogs this
is my number one relaxed animal an
amazing oh yeah we were talking about
like service dogs and we like to forget
but you know types of all the signs of
stuff and you guys will never know what
we talked about we smoked it into the
air so is there if the sound waves were
here guys if sound is sacred and you
touch the air you essentially heard our
words and touch them and absorb them so
this is our conversations on like 20 men
express a little take nervous dancers
well you guys have a great week thanks
for hanging out with us for another
episode we'll see you guys next another
[ __ ] long distance
[Music]
[Music]